- I was just very focused on
not falling, walking in here.
- I gotta be honest with you,
I was very focused on the fact
that you play a younger version of her
and you're taller (laughs)
- How dare you?
- OK, I am-
- How dare you? Listen you, OK?
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I'm like, "I'm five, three
and a half." I just love-
- I'm five, four and a half.
- I was like, "Half counts."
I just was you, so I walk
out here, I was like,
"Well, that's interesting."
(Mila and Chiara laugh)
I didn't recognize that in the film.
Did a good job.
But you started acting so young,- at 11.
- Yeah, yeah.
- How in the world did
you convince your mother,
your parents to do that?
- With a lot of effort let me tell you.
My mom was actually
pretty strongly against me
being in the industry at first.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. So I kind of always-
- [Mila] Oh my God.
(audience murmur their appreciation)
- [Kelly] Oh dear Lord.
Adorable little thing.
- [Chara] Please take it away.
(everyone laughs)
- [Mila] No, you're so cute.
- No, I always wanted to act.
It was kind of always a dream
of mine from a very young age,
even when I was like four or five.
I wanted to do theater.
- [Kelly] Really?
- Yeah, I wanted to do
everything in school-
- Did something happen that you like...
I remember I saw a musical
and I was like, 'Oh my gosh",
like this is what I'm meant to do.
- What was the musical? Do you remember?
= It's "Les Miz" and I-
- Oh.
- And I went on scholarship
to like New York
with this team of people.
And I saw, and it like,
that's what made me.
I was like a sophomore in high school.
I was like, "Oh my God,
I must do something
like this in my life."
So was there something that happened
when you were really
little? Does your mom know?
Like, I'm just curious how,
you know, like that early?
That's amazing.
- I don't know.
I don't have an exact answer.
I can't like pinpoint a moment.
I mean, I was obsessed with musicals
when I was young as well.
Like I loved "The Sound of
Music" and "Wizard of Oz"
and like "Chitty Chitty Bang Bang"
or like anything like that.
- Solid Classics.
- [Chara] Yes, yes.
- [Kelly] All right.
- But I loved anything like entertainment.
I wanted to sit through,
you know, "Cirque du Soleil"
and TV shows and everything
from being like a little kid.
And my mom was surprised
because I guess, you know,
most kids get distracted
or they start crying,
but I would kind of be like
totally caught up in the screen.
- [Kelly] Hyper-focused.
- Yes so focused.
- Wow.
- And I always wanted to do things
kind of in that performance element.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- At school and everything.
But my mom was like,
"You need to wait until you're 18,
"You need to wait until you're older,
'You need to have a normal childhood
and on the playground and ride bicycle".
- Well, it doesn't always
end well for child actors.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's why
she probably, there's, you know
sometimes it doesn't go well.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm here now.
- Yeah.
- No, you're great.
That's what I'm saying.
I wouldn't have said
it if it was the other-
- I know, I was like,
"It's all turned terribly".
- No, it can be hard because
especially you're growing up
in a different generation than us.
Like it's already hard
enough to be a child actor,
- [Mila] Much different.
- [Chiara] Stop it.
- No, I know, but I'm just
saying it's, it's different.
You're on, you're online.
Like it's a completely
different world of bullying.
It's a completely different
world of growing up
in, in public, like everyone is.
- Yeah.
- so it's kind of hard.
So, but I think you're amazing
for such a young, so young actor.
You started young as well.
- I was nine.
- Yeah. Good God, you two.
- Yeah, I know.
- You Knew that early too.
- Oh my God, I, I was obsessed.
- Well okay.
- Obsessed. I still love it.
Like I've, you know, 30
years into it and I like
for all the things that are
wrong with this industry,
there's so many things that this industry
allowed me to do that no
other industry in the world
would I be able to be here today
on the Kelly Clarkson show.
Like it wouldn't exist.
Like I wouldn't be able to do it.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
To sit here to be able to like,
it's incredible life. I've
been, I mean, honestly, like
I'm so grateful every single day.
- (knocking on table) I'm
knocking for you (laughs).
- So you both play this same woman
at different points in her life
in "Luckiest Girl Alive.
So let's take a look
at Chiara in the movie.
- Is it true?
I had no idea Arthur was
gonna do something like that.
I would've told you some more.
- Not that part. The part about the boys.
- I didn't want to mom. I
was drunk. They're lying.
- Oh my god, Tiffany, this
is why I say "no drinking".
Well, I'm gonna call a
lawyer as soon as I get home.
(voice breaking) What
are people gonna say?
- Mom?
Mom?
- No, Tiffany.
No, no.
You disgust me.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
(audience claps)
So Ani deals with many societal pressures.
As a young woman yourself,
how do you deal with societal pressures?
'Cause like again, I, you grew up in a
different environment than we did.
- Yeah. I mean, I think there's
a lot of pressure today.
I think friends place pressure on you,
Family can place pressure on you.
Society, in general,
places a lot of pressure.
There's a lot of expectation
about who you're supposed to be
and how you're supposed to act,
and how you're supposed to seem.
And something we've talked about a lot
is the difference between,
you know, the person
or persona that you present,
you know, on the internet,
especially as an actress, where,
you know, you want to feel
like you're perfect all the
time, which is not human.
Humans are not perfect.
We're not meant to be perfect.
We're meant to make mistakes and mess up
and, and, and do things
wrong, and learn and grow.
Like, how are you supposed to get older
if you can never, you
know learn from mistakes.
You're just gonna be
stunted pretty much forever.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I think
there's a huge pressure
when it comes to that.
I mean, I, we were talking
about how we, you know,
I grew up with social
media and Mila didn't,
and that is hard, it's really hard.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mila] But you're also
incredible at not feeding into it.
We've talked about this.
- Well, thank you.
- You're very good at separating
what you do and who you are.
- That's very difficult for adults,
let alone young individuals.
- I know, I think that you're
gonna, you're gonna be fine.
But like, but I think that that's the
the minority in this twenty
something year old industry.
- [Kelly] Yeah.